nos piden escoger la opción correcta y
parece que todas las opciones tratan de
cuál es el límite de fx cuando nos
aproximamos a 6 de cualquier lado ya sea
por el lado derecho o ya sea por el lado
izquierdo así que hay que pensar en eso
primero permítanme hacer el lado
izquierdo entonces el límite df de x
cuando x tiende a 6 por la izquierda a
quien va a ser igual bueno cuando nos
aproximamos por el lado izquierdo
podemos ver que f de 4 está un poco
debajo de 2
efe de 5 parece que está alrededor de 3
efe de 5.5 parece estar aún más arriba
efe de 5.75 hasta se sale de la gráfica
así que parece que esto va a infinito en
dirección positiva es decir que esta
función no está acotada entonces podemos
decir que esto de aquí es más infinito y
si pensamos en el límite de fx cuando x
tiende a 6 por la derecha
a que va a ser igual esto bueno aquí ft
7 es negativo
efe de 6.5 es aún más negativo efe de
6.1 es mucho más negativo y ahora si
pensamos ene efe de 6.01 va a ser mucho
mucho mucho más negativo que eso así que
parece que esto va hacia infinito pero
en una dirección negativa entonces esto
de aquí serían menos infinito y ya con
esto vamos a ver cuál de nuestras
opciones coincide con nuestro resultado
observa que la manera en la que lo
listaron fue poner primero el límite por
la derecha así que este es el límite
cuando x se aproxima a 6 por valores
mayores que 6
tenemos que eran menos infinito entonces
tenemos que la respuesta está entre
estas dos opciones ya que estas dos
dicen justo eso y entonces voy a
descartar estas otras dos opciones y
luego pensemos cuando nos aproximamos a
seis por el lado izquierdo y vamos a ver
que eso es más infinito así que la
opción correcta es esta de aquí vamos a
descartar está
y ya hemos acabado